[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM DENNISS: I'm William
Denniss, a product manager
for GKE Autopilot.
I'm excited to introduce
a new mode of operation
for Google Kubernetes Engine
that we think you will like.
If you're new to Kubernetes,
it's the industry-standard way
to deploy and manage
application containers,
making it efficient
to develop and publish
internet-based applications.
GKE was the first managed
Kubernetes service
to the market over five years
ago and remains the most
scalable and reliable platform,
with an industry-leading
15,000-node capability.
And it's brought to
you by a team that
makes more technical
contributions to the Kubernetes
project than any other company.
Kubernetes gives you a
container application platform
on which to run your services.
But what does it actually
take to run this platform?
There's quite a lot of aspects,
from the control plane,
provisioning, and
management, to worker node
creation and patching.
Since its launch, GKE has taken
care of most of these elements
for you.
But there are a couple
of things that were still
your responsibility, like
configuring and managing
node pools.
We figured out what
you really care
about most is running your
own applications and services
on GKE, and not the configuring
and monitoring of the computer
they run on.
So we looked at what
more we could do to help.
That's why I'm
happy to introduce
GKE Autopilot, a new mode
of operation for GKE.
With Autopilot, the node
configuration and management
is now our
responsibility, as well,
so you can focus more on your
own applications and services
that run on top.
With Autopilot, everything
is autoprovisioned.
All you need to do is name
the cluster, pick a region,
set the network, and deploy
your workload with Kubernetes.
And once things are
provisioned, Google
is responsible for managing the
nodes and keeping them running.
When it comes to the bill,
you pay for pods and not VMs.
Let me drill into each of
these a little further.
I mentioned that with
Autopilot, we have
autoprovisioned everything.
What this means in practice is
that your pod and deployment
configuration is also the
complete cluster specification.
We provision compute resources
based on the resource
needs you specify
in your pod spec.
There's minimal cluster
setup, with no need
to figure out what
size and shape of nodes
should be provided
for your workloads.
We also apply all the latest
security best practices
automatically.
You've already been able
to offload many cluster
operational
responsibilities to Google,
and now this applies
to nodes, as well.
And since we're now
managing the nodes,
they're more locked
down, which also
serves to prevent accidental or
intentional modifications that
can cause issues.
Even with us
managing everything,
you can still use features like
maintenance windows and pod
disruption budgets to govern
how and when updates occur.
In fact, we're so
confident of our management
of this new platform, that
we're offering a pod-level SLA
in GKE for the first time.
This SLA offers three
nines of uptime for pods
running in multiple zones.
The other major difference
is how you're billed.
Since you now specify your
resources at a pod level,
that's how you're
billed, as well.
Your pods are billed per second
for vCPU, memory, and disk
resource requests.
System components, the
operating system overhead,
and, most importantly,
unused capacity,
is no longer your concern.
Once you scale a workload
down, the associated charges
cease immediately.
GKE's free tier
includes Autopilot,
giving you one free zone
or Autopilot cluster.
So you can give it a try
and just pay for the pods
you deploy.
Despite being fully
managed, GKE Autopilot
is still GKE and supports
nearly the full gamut
of workload capabilities.
Workloads requiring
StatefulSet and even DaemonSet
are supported at launch, and
more support is on the roadmap.
We think you shouldn't
have to compromise
when it comes to your
Kubernetes application platform
and built Autopilot
with that in mind.
From the outset, we
said to ourselves
that Autopilot is GKE, and we
want you to hold us to that.
Popular administrative
workloads from our partners,
in areas like logging
and monitoring,
are either supported
now or on the roadmap.
Basically, the only
workloads we don't
expect to be compatible with
this new mode of operation
are custom administrative
workloads that
might be used for low-level
node management tasks,
exactly the kind of
thing which we hope
won't be needed in Autopilot.
And one more thing--
we've actually been
running a private preview
for a few months, and
I'm pleased to announce
that Autopilot is launching as
generally available and ready
for your production workloads.
With that, I'd like to take you
through a quick demo of what
Autopilot can do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To create an Autopilot
cluster, all you need to do
is give it a name, pick
your favorite region,
and set the network, if you
have any particular networking
requirements.
In my case, I'll leave the
network as the default Public
cluster and click Create.
Creation takes a
couple of minutes,
so let me switch to one
I've created earlier.
To connect to this cluster,
I click the Connect button
and copy the connection
command to my clipboard.
Now, from the command line,
I'll paste that command
to authenticate kubectl so
it can access the cluster.
The demo I'm going
to deploy today
is from the GKE
sample repository.
So let's clone that
repository from GitHub
and change into the
sample directory.
Finally, I'm going to apply
the Kubernetes configuration
of the guestbook sample.
Now, this sample consists
of a PHP frontend
with a Redis backend.
If you've deployed
Redis before, you'll
be aware it does have a
few resource requirements.
In the past, you may have had
to configure your node pools
to ensure that they
have enough capacity.
But with Autopilot,
we do that for you.
This takes about a
minute to provision,
so I'm just going to skip ahead.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's go ahead and grab the
IP address of this sample
application and check it out.
So I pasted that IP address
into my browser, loaded it up,
and I can give it a quick test.
And that was Autopilot.
With the introduction
of Autopilot,
GKE is now available in two
modes of operation, standard
and Autopilot.
Standard is the
experience that we've
been building since
the launch of GKE,
where you have full
control over the nodes
with the ability
to finetune things
to your heart's content--
for example, running custom
administrative workloads--
and even tweaking the node
operating system itself.
Autopilot is a hands-off,
fully-managed solution
that empowers you to
focus on your workloads
while we take care of the rest.
Both modes of operation are
generally available and fully
supported by Google Cloud,
so please choose whichever
best suits your needs.
To learn more about Autopilot,
please follow this link
to g.co/autopilot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]